>>> W DEVELOPMENT IN RUSSIA'S
TACK IN UKRAINE.
TWO FAMILIES WHO WENT TO AID SAY
THEIR LOVED ONES HAVE BEEN
MISSING FOR A WEEK.
ALEXANDER JOHN ROBERT DRUKE WAS
LAST SEEN JUNE 9th.
THE UKRAINIAN UNIT THEY WERE
WITH WAS FIGHTING IN A TOWN
OUTSIDE OF KHARKIV WHERE THE
FIGHTING HAS BEEN INTENSE.
THEY BOTH WENT MISSING DURING
BATTLE.
THE SEARCH MISSIONS HAVE FAILED
TO FIND ANY REMAINS.
THE RUSSIAN SOCIAL MEDIA CHANNEL
SAYS THEY HAVE CAPTURED THE TWO
MEN.
THAT HAS NOT BEEN CONFIRMED.
JOINING ME NOW FOR AN EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW, FIANCE AND THE
MOTHER.
JOY, WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT WHEN
AND WHERE YOUR FIANCE ANDY AND
BUNNY'S SON ALEXANDER WERE LAST
SEEN?
>> AS FAR AS I KNOW, IT WAS
THURSDAY.
I THINK THAT WAS THE 9th.
AND IT WAS DURING AN OPERATION
IN THE KHARKIV REGION OF UKRAINE
NEAR A TOWN I THINK IT'S CALLED
IZBITSKE.
I COULD BE PRONOUNCING THAT
INCORRECTLY.
IT'S AROUND THERE.
>> BUNNY, BOTH YOUR SON AND ANDY
ARE MILITARY VETERANS.
DID ALEXANDER TALK TO YOU ABOUT
WHY HE WANTED TO GO TO TRAVEL TO
UKRAINE AND FIGHT?
>> OH, YES.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT FOR ABOUT A
MONTH BEFORE HE MADE THE FINAL
DECISION.
HE FELT VERY STRONGLY.
HE -- FIRST, HE'S ONE OF THE
MOST LOYAL AMERICANS YOU WOULD
EVER HOPE TO MEET AND HE WAS
PROUD TO SERVE HIS COUNTRY.
HE SAID, MOM, I REALLY NEED TO
GO AND HELP FIGHT IN UKRAINE.
IF PUTIN IS NOT STOPPED THERE,
HE'S NOT GOING TO BE SATISFIED.
HE'LL BECOME EMBOLDENED AND
EVENTUALLY AMERICANS WILL BE
THREATENED AND HE NEEDS TO BE
STOPPED NOW.
ALEX DIDN'T GO TO FIGHT.
HE SAID, I HAVE THE SKILLS TO
HELP TRAIN UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS
AND HELP THEM LEARN HOW TO USE
THE WEAPONS THAT AMERICA WAS
SENDING OVER THERE.
>> JOY, WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME
YOU SPOKE WITH ANDY?
>> IT WAS ALSO A TEXT MESSAGE ON
JUNE 8th.
WE HAD BEEN KIND OF HAVING A
NORMAL CONVERSATION, A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT FOOD AND THEN HE TOLD
ME HE LOVED ME VERY MUCH AND
THAT HE WOULD BE UNAVAILABLE FOR
TWO TO THREE DAYS.
>> DID HE TALK TO YOU ABOUT WHAT
HE HAD BEEN EXPERIENCING SO FAR?
>> I THINK HE WAS TRYING NOT TO
WORRY ME SO HE DIDN'T REALLY
TELL ME WHEN HE WAS DOING THINGS
LIKE THAT.
ALL I KNEW IS WHEN HE WAS
JOINING AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
>> BUNNY, I UNDERSTAND YOU'VE
BEEN IN CONTACT WITH THE U.S.
EMBASSY.
IF YOU CAN, WHAT ARE THEY
TELLING YOU ABOUT WHERE
ALEXANDER AND ANDY MIGHT BE?
>> THEY ARE TELLING ME THAT THEY
ARE DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
LOCATE THEM, THAT THEY HAD
NOTHING VERIFIED YET AND FOR ME
TO -- FOR JOY AND ME TO REMAIN
ENCOURAGED AND KNOW THAT THEY
ARE DOING THINGS BEHIND THE
SCENES DAY AND NIGHT, 24/7.
THEY'RE GOING TO FIND THEM.
>> JOY, YOU'RE BEING TOLD THE
SAME THING?
>> PRETTY MUCH.
I HAVEN'T HAD DIRECT PHONE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE EMBASSY
BUT ALL OF THE OFFICIAL CHANNELS
I'VE GONE THROUGH HAVE PRETTY
MUCH SAID THE SAME THING.
THEY'VE ALL BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE
AND VERY HELPFUL AND THEY'RE ALL
TAKING IT REALLY SERIOUSLY AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
>> BUNNY, HOW ARE YOU HOLDING
UP?
>> WELL, I'M TRYING TO REMAIN
STRONG AND CALM BECAUSE GETTING
UPSET WON'T HELP ALEX AT ALL.
BUT HEARING JOY FOR THE FIRST
TIME, THIS IS DIFFICULT
BECAUSE -- BECAUSE I FEEL FOR
HER.
MOST OF THE TIME I'M REALLY
STRONG BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT ALEX
WOULD WANT.
>> YOU'RE BOTH REALLY STRONG.
I KNOW THIS IS IMPOSSIBLY HARD.
JOY, YOU AND ANDY ARE ENGAGED.
WHAT DO YOU WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW
ABOUT HIM?
>> HE'S JUST SO STRONG AND HE
HAS SUCH A BIG HEART.
HE DIDN'T GO THERE FOR SELFISH
REASONS OR ANYTHING.
HE REALLY HAD THIS NAWING AT HIS
HEART AND THIS BIG BURDEN TO GO
AND SERVE THE PEOPLE HOWEVER HE
CAN AND JUST -- I'M VERY PROUD
OF HIM.
I JUST WANT TO SEE HIM BACK
SAFELY.
>> BUNNY, IS THERE ANYTHING ELSE
YOU WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW?
>> I WANT EVERYONE TO KNOW FIRST
OF ALL IF THEY'RE TOGETHER, ANDY
AND ALEX, WE DON'T WANT ONE TO
COME HOME WITHOUT THE OTHER.
THEY WERE BEST BUDDIES THERE AND
WE WANT EVERYBODY TO REMEMBER
THAT IT'S NOT JUST ONE PERSON
THERE.
AND THE SECOND THING IS FOR THEM
TO KNOW THAT IT WAS NOT -- ALEX
DID NOT GO THERE AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE U.S.
MILITARY, HE WENT THERE AS A
CIVILIAN WITH MILITARY TRAINING.
HE WENT THERE ON HIS OWN.
HE WAS NOT SENT THERE BY OUR
GOVERNMENT.
>> JOY, ANYTHING ELSE YOU WANT
TO SAY?
>> ANDY, TOO.
WHAT SHE JUST SAID AS WELL.
HE WENT THERE TO VOLUNTEER.
AND HE WASN'T --